[Applaus]
bei uns war der morgen definitiv um
einiges flotter wie normal dastehen
wir haben erstmal klaus müssen gleich
mal zum frühstück genießen und dann noch
ist nun endlich auf die jeder aufgelesen
worden
und ich glaube daran ob jeder da ist und
das kann und nach dem namen verlesen
sagen wir dann zustandes kontrolle und
mehr zitieren wenn der herr
oberstleutnant morgenpost online mit
einer überzeugung von lautstark guten
morgen herr oberst lehrern verstanden
[Musik]
mehr
links
ja der stand ist kontrolle noch kommt
ist interessant mit einer guten kennt
wird erst mal marschiert und guter dinge
dass mir diese weise kunden land company
rechtsschutz
aufgrund dessen dass in der kaserne über
100 mann guckt dann hat die
kleiderausgabe länger dort und hätten
die letzten sachen aus brust und po der
befehlsausgabe haben wir noch ein rolle
in uniform druck standen zum schluss ist
noch nur die fahnen waren und jetzt
commons aufs eigene bett weder ohne 13
zimmer kollegin mit dem lauterer ins
wochenende ableiten
[Musik]